Oi, pessoal. Deixa eu te fazer uma
pergunta. E se eu te dissesse que existe
uma combinação pouco comentada que pode
ajudar de forma real uma resposta
antiinflamatória em apenas 30 dias? Sim,
hoje vamos falar sobre a combinação de
queina e bromelaína, abordando com uma
visão funcional o que a literatura mais
recente está sugerindo, os mecanismos,
os resultados preliminares e o que
considerar com cuidado. Fique comigo
porque ao final você vai entender o
porquê, o como e os caveiates, né? os
porém, né, as pegadinhas e vai conseguir
avaliar se isso pode fazer sentido para
você. Agora vamos juntos primeiro,
entender os protagonistas, o que que é
quecetina, o que que é bromelaína,
depois como eles podem interagir, qual o
protocolo sugerido na visão funcional em
30 dias e por fim o que que os estudos
dizem, o que não está claro e que você
precisa observar. Vamos lá. Para
começar, a quecetina é um flavonol
presente em muitos alimentos. está na
cebola roxa, na maçã, no chá verde.
Estudos recentes apontam que ela exerce
efeitos anti-inflamatórios via múltiplos
caminhos redução do estresse oxidativo,
modulação de metabolismo, influência no
equilíbrio intestinal e até no perfil
imune. Por exemplo, polarização de
macrófagos. Já a bromelaína é um
conjunto de enzimas proteíticas
extraídas do abacaxi e possui também
função antiedema analgésica e
antiinflamatória. Ou seja, ambas t
perfil de combate à inflamação, cada uma
com seu estilo. Agora que você sabe quem
são os atores, vamos colocar juntos no
palco queina e bromelaína. A ideia da
combinação é que possam se potencializar
a quecetina modulando as vias de
citocinas, NFK beta, etc.
Abromelaína, facilitando a dissolução de
mediadores, edema, possivelmente
melhorando a absorção ou efeito
cinérgico. Na visão funcional, o
protocolo de 30 dias poderia seguir algo
como usar quecetina em dose ótima.
Tomemos como exemplo 500 mg por dia
dividido, mais bromelaína em dose que
favoreça a atividade enzimática, sempre
com acompanhamento clínico, jejum ou
entre refeições, ajustando paraa sua
condição, peso, função hepática ou
renal, interações medicamentosas. Vale
frisar, não é remédio, tampouco
substitui avaliação médica, é uma
intervenção coadjuvante. Agora vamos ao
que a literatura mais recente revela. E
aqui entram os porénens importantes. Um
estudo de revisão de 2025 sobre
quecetina mostrou que ela tem forte
evidência pré-clínica para reduzir
inflamação em diversos sistemas:
gestório, respiratório, endócrino,
óstearticular, via mecanismo de estresse
oxidativo, modulação imune, etc. Um
outro estudo em modelo animal com
cobidando bromelaína eccetina no que foi
descrito como artrite experimental
mostrou que após 30 dias se observou
redução de vários marcadores
inflamatórios que foram quase
normalizados após a dose de combinação.
Isso sugere um potencial real dentro de
modelo para abordagem antifamatória.
Mas, e é um grande más, há poucos ou
nenhuns grandes ensaios clínicos humanos
robustos com milhares de pessoas, duplo
cego, etc., que teste quecetina mais
bombenaína por 30 dias com protocolo
padrão, ou seja, muita promessa, menos
confirmação. Por exemplo, existe um
estudo clínico que avalia gel de
bromelaína com quercetina em
periodontite, que já foi concluído em
2024, mas não é o mesmo cenário de uso
oral generalizado. Logo, se você quiser
aplicar, esteja ciente da limitação de
evidência. Voltando à visão funcional,
se eu fosse desenhar um roteiro prático
para 30 dias, eu diria algo assim,
relembrando que eu não estou
prescrevendo, estou exemplificando. Dias
1 a 30, quecetina 500 mg dia, por
exemplo, 250 mg duas vezes entre
refeições. Dia 1 a 30, bromelaína. A
dose dependeria da potência, por
exemplo, algo equivalente a 500 a 1000
mg ou conforme unidade enzimática em
jejum para favorecer a absorção
sistêmica e efeito antiedema. Junto, dar
suporte, estilo dividido
antiinflamatório, sono adequado, evitar
alimentos ultraprocessados, controlar
estresse, manter a atividade física
moderada, porque sem isso o efeito
máximo não acontece. Monitorar
inflamação, por exemplo, através do
marcador proteína ser reativa. Também
monitorar a função renal e hepática,
qualquer interação medicamentosa,
especialmente se os anticoagulantes ou
enzimas hepáticas. No dia 30, avaliar a
resposta. Se houve melhores de sintomas
como dor articular, edema e sensação
geral de menos inflamação, então decidir
continuidade ou ajuste. Na conclusão,
esta é uma abordagem complementar
baseada em evidência emergente, mas
visão funcional. não substitui o
tratamento convencional, nem a avaliação
de médico, nutricionista ou profissional
de saúde. Então, para fechar, em resumo,
a combinação de quecetina mais
bromenaína parece promissora como
estratégia antiflamatória em 30 dias,
baseada em modelos animais e revisões
recentes que mostram os mecanismos. Mas
a evidência humana ainda é limitada. Se
fizer sentido para você, deve ser usado
como parte de um pacote maior,
alimentação, sono, movimento e com
supervisão. E se houver medicação
concomitante ou condição médica,
avaliação obrigatória. Agora saia do
vídeo se você gosta de ficar no
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade conveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens e
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica. Casos de reversão
que parecem possíveis, combinações offel
que funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Live semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. Não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
M.